when most people think about the Cold
War they think about two ideological
factions vying for global supremacy what
isn't often talked about is the
infighting which occurred in both camps
the most important of these conflicts
was the sino-soviet split which sold the
People's Republic of China denounced the
USSR and go its own way so what caused
the split and what long-term effects did
it have prior to the Second World War
China was embroiled in a civil war which
saw the Communists fighting against the
Chinese Republic this conflict was
halted when the Japanese invaded and
both sides allied against the foreign
threat which was due in part to a great
deal of pressure from a certain Joseph
Stalin the Japanese lost and by the time
of their surrender China looked like
this with the USSR occupying Manchuria
which had promptly handed over to the
Communists and the leader Mao Zedong the
civil war resumed and in the end the
Communists won given the USSR a new
powerful ally both sides signed a
friendship treaty in 1950 and so things
were looking up for both of them also
unlike the Communist States in Eastern
Europe China was an independent nation a
Moscow couldn't appoint or dismiss its
leaders nor control its internal policy
since it was independent it's led to the
Chinese leadership applying the
communist model in a fundamentally
different way to the USSR Stalinism and
Maoism were rapidly diverging and this
difference became even more pronounced
when Stalin died and was succeeded by
Nikita Khrushchev the divisions between
the two communist States span both
internal and external policies in terms
of internal policy the USSR disagreed
with Mao's Great Leap Forward in its
implementation mouthes approached a
change for the Chinese government
hastily reformed agriculture and demand
that it output unreasonable amounts
these policies exacerbated a major
drought which hit China between 1959 and
1961 which saw the deaths of at least 15
million people to make matters worse Mao
also opted to continue with the policy
of exporting grain because he wanted
China to look like it was a wealthy
well-fed country furthermore Mao
disliked the reforms undertaken by
Nikita Khrushchev which he felt were
fundamentally on communist Mao also saw
Khrushchev's use of the Red Army to put
down the 1956 Hungarian Revolution as de
legitimizing communism internationally
which brings us on to conflicts of a
foreign policy
Khrushchev had taken a different
approach to the USSR's relationship with
the West and had pursued a policy of
peaceful coexistence when a series of
foreign policy clashes between the USSR
and the USA ended with Khrushchev
backing down Mao decided that communism
needed a new leader one who would
confront the West on all fronts at every
opportunity while
these may sound like issues which could
have been papered over for Mao and
Khrushchev ideological purity was a
matter of life or death for communism in
the end these disagreements led to the
USSR formally breaking off diplomatic
relations with the PRC in late 1961 in
mid 1962 Mao opted to break off
relations with the USSR and hereafter
the Communist world was fractured and
would remain so during the Cold War
China never managed to take leadership
of the Communist world but it did have
some communist states which opted to
follow the principles of Maoism and was
the division of the Communist states of
the world was overwhelmingly in favor of
the Soviet Union EDA presented with new
difficulties the 1960s saw China embrace
a much more aggressive foreign policy
which saw it develop its own nuclear
weapons and also fight border conflicts
with Taiwan India and also the USSR
although in the end Mouse which from an
ideological foreign policy to a
pragmatic one which saw him restore and
even improve relations with the US in
the West the People's Republic of China
Hereafter pursued its own goals and
given that it outlasted the USSR the
sino-soviet split didn't seem to
negatively affect it too much I hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching with extra thanks to my patreon
supporters which you can see on screen
and with an extra special thanks to
James Bissonnette David archaeologist
Ozark a flash Party Boyko Rob Waterhouse
Chris wicker Michael Reynolds Gustav
Swan David Silverman spinning three
plates
Maggie packs Kowski Christian check'
Anthony Beckett Ike Skye Chappell and
Winston K word
you